from the blockbuster franchise that all
intelligent people avoid comes the most
forgettable Twilight movie yet
Twilight Eclipse witness the
continuation of one of the most forced
love triangles in film history where
this shirtless guy is clearly a third
wheel we don't need you to handle
anything huh because she told him in
previous movies and in this movie that
she will always choose shovel face
you're marrying him but that won't stop
her from leading him on asking you to
kiss me just so they can continue to
sell Team Jacob t-shirts and pad the
running time with three-way stand
prepare yourself for two hours of filler
like laying in bed walking around
outside villain standing around doing
nothing and pointless flashbacks or
minor characters a movie so gay
it has groups of shirtless boys shovel
face refusing sex and the tense scene
out of Brokeback Mountain
I am hotter than you an actress so
terrible have you she speaks with weird
long pauses imprinted on someone we're
gonna talk about this but you it
wouldn't be hmm you looked worried my
life is enough miserable Edward is old
school and three movies in still has the
same dumb expression is every director
afraid to tell her to close her mouth a
final battle so unfulfilling it's built
up an entire movie but it's over in
about a minute and doesn't have any
impact on the overall saga a film so
bland
oh no this again even we're running out
of things to be honest about twilight
eclipse it's lazy even by twilight
standards don't forget to watch this
sweet screen junkies episode where dad's
answer Twilight trivia for their
daughter
we made an eleven-year-old cry and tell
me something you'd like to hear me say
in my epic voice in a world where
puppy's murderer
fun this is snake colonel do you read me
Mahna Mahna I'm a strong independent
black woman who don't need no man